oh my God the aliens are swifties
that's why they came here they came they
couldn't get concert tickets on their
world
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here you're a personal astrophysicist
got Chuck Nice on the line Chuck how you
doing man hey what's happening Neil all
right this is a a cosmic queries yes
this is so popular I'm I'm amazed just
how how many people like to listen to
other people's questions and usually
they probably got some questions of
their own inquiring minds want to know
and so this is a grab bag on any subject
at all that's right do we solicit grab
bag or is this just leftovers from other
ones that were not grab bags I know well
we actually asked people do they want to
uh send us some grab bag questions oh
okay yeah some there you have it we have
a favorite because they're so Random you
know yeah well that's what makes it fun
you know I think they're hip to it uh to
that as well when you're all right when
you see well let's jump into it shall we
and these are patreon supporters oh
that's right yeah they have exclusive
access to the question line here and
well you know so many people were
sending in questions that we've had to
figure out a way to Cull it down and we
figured the best way to call it down is
to also make some money
um
it was five dollars a month man and you
can ask whatever you would like no the
truth is that uh you know we need
support through patreon and we figure
why not make this a patreon perk as a
reward for the people who are so
gracious as to support us all right here
we go this is uh Victor Ray Rutledge who
says hey Chuck and Neil here's my
question out of Texas a truly weird
space in the Multiverse
since humans can vaguely see infrared
and ultraviolet radiation what other
things in the physical world do we just
ignore since they have always been
ignored oh beautiful question so I write
about this in I forgot which book let me
think okay that is the most humble brag
I've ever heard oh my God you're
insufferable you know I wrote about this
once
I can't quite recall which one of my
many Publications uh where I place this
particular information okay I guarantee
it's in death by black hole and other
Cosmic quandaries okay um but there's a
chapter in there called coming to our
senses all right and it's all about the
fact that we have our traditional five
senses right we know and love
and consider that before science
took on Technology and Engineering right
why would you think
that the world
had stuff in it that you couldn't sense
right we're seeing your touch or taste
there's no reason to even have that
thought because it's all happening I'm
seeing it all I'm teaching it all and
all I've tasted it all away and and
you're telling me and if you're
religious why would God make you have
all these senses that were that and when
you're still when you're practically
blind to what's actually happening out
there right right so so there was strong
philosophical cultural emotional
requirements that our five senses saw
everything Anton Van Leeuwenhoek okay
Optical lens maker right and he had the
sense who do I get to say that now he
had the
the the Curiosity
to say I wonder what would happen if I
looked at a drop of pond water
in my new microscope
to even have that thought it's just
water yeah why are you looking at a
transparent liquid it can't be anything
interesting there and that was the day
that he stopped drinking water forever
dehydrated body in the corner of the
closet it looked at that he was just
like oh my God
never put this stuff inside of you he
saw all kinds of creatures and I love
what he could you know what word he used
to describe him no animal kills animal
kills prettily a swimming prettily as
swimming oh my God that's that's
actually so he wrote this up and sent it
to the Royal Society
and they thought he was just pulling
their leg Yeah right and they said you
know okay this is a this is fun to read
but next time put put down the Gin
before you write to him exactly
step away from the bottle and the good
thing about science among many things is
they can be skeptical of that report who
wouldn't be but
you can go check it out right okay you
can build one of these yourself you can
look at your pond water so the
verification of an extraordinary claim
is fundamental to the advance of science
so there's something your senses can't
see
you have sight
so a microscope magnifies your site
so that you see things that were
otherwise completely outside of your
awareness right and Medicine could not
have it made the achievements it did
without the microscope the microscope so
it's not that God punished you for being
bad and that's why you have this disease
somebody something bit you right and
there's a bacterium or a virus or and
you can track the flow of diseases in
this right so and not only that God
still could have punished you with the
bite you know okay you could have let
the animal bite you so that you know
okay you get what's coming to you yeah
yeah so we were off and running to the
small and to the large all of which you
can't see
okay
let's keep going in
my book uh once again that's shut up
which was this astrophysics of people in
a hurry yes which I think has some of
this senses
uh discussion in it I recount
the discovery of infrared right okay I
think we did we have an explainer on
that one we might one of my favorite
stories oh yeah because he's looking at
the Spectrum this is uh William Herschel
after Newton did his thing with the
prism and the colors of the rainbow just
deducing that the colors of the rainbow
are embedded in white light right
freaking out artists of the day but
that's the physics of it and he said I
wonder what temperature the different
colors are
and so he puts thermometers into the
different colors of the rainbow
projected on his table but you need a
control thermometer a thermometer that
just simply measures the air temperature
without the influence of the code so he
puts one off to the side of the red
and death thermometer measured a higher
temperature than everybody I love them
so he's freaking out and he says I may
have discovered light unfit for vision
wow
invisible light and so so
go from then onward when someone says oh
I have a sixth sense
you know I don't even I don't even have
that conversation because I say I'm a
scientist and I have 12 senses
I could detect ultraviolet infrared
x-rays gamma rays radio waves microwaves
you can't all right I have tools oh you
can if you had these tools I can also
detect gravitational vectors ionizing
radiation I can detect Small Things big
things in things too far away for you to
see or even notice well
so the answer is yes
the universe brims with things outside
of our senses and modern science
is okay with that because we don't rely
on our senses to decode the universe
nice there it is
excellent all right this is Minaj menos
menos chug
uh and thank you we can't be right but
go ahead no no no no no no that's that's
he spelled it out for me he goes okay
okay hello Neil and hello Chuck this is
Manoj chug uh it's as in chug a beer
Chuck uh so yeah
exactly that's a good that's a good man
or person here uh he says I'm from
playing the Plainview Long Island I'm a
recent intern as a part Star Talk Patron
and although I've been a huge fan of you
guys for a long time my question is with
the recent success
of uh
chandraian India's unnamed moon mission
to the Moon South Pole pulled off at a
super low budget
of just 75 million macaroons
um do you see NASA collaborating with
the Indian space and research
organization for future space admissions
launching astronauts and payloads to the
ISS Etc as a more cost effective option
compared to SpaceX and other private
agencies so I love my man it's just like
is India NASA's new dollar store a
dollar store
so yeah India so our missions that do
what India's Mission would do right
would cost 2x 5x 10x what India that's
74 million dollars that's a low budget
action movie in Hollywood isn't that
something except 75 million dollars
right oh right so so we have a lot to
learn about how they did it on the cheap
the issue here is not how cheap it is in
the absolute but how cheap it is for the
government to have done it
so in our world the government does it
it's expensive as many things are when
you do them first then you port it off
to private Enterprise that trims fat and
this sort of thing and so I don't know
that if Elon had to put a satellite on
the South Pole whether he couldn't have
done it for 75 million or even less
right but NASA can't do it for 75 or
less or they never have so that's my
first point second
uh
the good thing about collaborations in
space is everybody gets to do what they
do best right and you bring it together
nice right so if India can get you there
on the cheap
but they don't have the experiment but
you have the experiment or they you know
you just mix and match the international
um
uh
you you mix and match the best features
of the international participants right
and the International Space Station is
kind of like that
but that being said
competition also kind of works
to stimulate Innovation and achievement
right so does profit so does profit
sorry
profits profits first remember
so I I don't see
uh I don't see every country always
collaborating because that's that's more
than what is necessary to make keep the
engine going but when it makes sense to
collaborate yes right and
uh when I met with Prime Minister Modi
of India he I asked him about the the
Artemis Accord which is a document
signed by modern Space Fairy Nations
where they promise each other to share
data right to to do this in peace as we
advance the frontier so if you share
data
that's a form of collaboration yes right
so they go to the South Pole they're
going to see where the ice is first they
share the data now we retool our mission
to the Moon with humans now they don't
have to look in the same way because
that's already been verified they can
look in a different way or look at a
different ways will they really do that
because now water on the moon becomes a
resource and when resources are scarce
people get kind of sketchy
that's true you mean are there going to
be Moon Wars to the crater Waters well
yeah because even though we said like
you know there's an agreement that says
nobody can plant a flag on the moon and
say this is ours this is our territory
this is a what you can do is take
resources
so now if we can if if if if people are
locating and finding a ways to extract
and utilize especially water because and
I learned this from you
water
is what is the propulsion system to take
you further into space yeah so you can
if you break apart the hydrogen and
oxygen and then bring them back together
it's highly exothermic right it's it's
jet fuel basically no no you have rocket
fuel rocket fuel so now why so if you
gotta find a bunch of ice up there
you're like damn we just found all this
Rocket Fuel I'm not giving this to the
United States why would that give this
to the United States and by the way uh
Manoj says uh uh dear Neil my apologies
on behalf of the anchor who recently
interviewed you from The prominent
Indian news network and kept referring
to The Far Side of the Moon as the Dark
Side of the Moon definitely he is not a
follower of Star Talk ah there you go so
he saw that broadcast yeah he saw the
broadcast yeah I was I did some major
Indian press that yeah yeah yeah very
cool very cool and me and Lodi were like
that you know no
I saw that though you made some
headlines talking to Modi he called for
you so that was yeah yeah yeah it was a
good thing what you said though talking
about how you know the idea of the
furtherance of scientific literacy in
the pursuit of these uh lofty goals in
space as great for the entire country
and therefore for the entire world
right the entire country would include
the one out of six residents of India
who are Muslim that's right and they're
Muslim children you know and so you know
I'm worried that he's got that yeah he's
got that tendency
let's find an enemy so you can vote for
me because I'm hard on the enemy and
that you know
in the long run that's destabilizing and
I'd like to think that space can bring
everybody together that's all yeah
exactly
hey Neil happy sweet 16. what this is
your 16th book coming out the one that
we started working on together two years
ago
this
well thank you yes it's my 16th book
practically forgot about because I've
been very busy and I guess it's coming
out in a month well it's my first book
so oh sorry we gotta do something sir so
I should be more excited that okay
absolutely
but I think this is your best friend
all right let's go on to uh Cicero
artifan and Cicero artifan says hello Dr
Tyson Hello Lord nice this is Cicero
artifan from Toronto Canada I've heard a
few people saying that maybe a more
advanced alien would not even see us
because we are just not Advanced enough
to be seen just like we don't care about
bugs and worms when we're building our
homes
is that really what you think with all
of our technological advancements
wouldn't aliens look at us and at least
perceive us we're we're able to do math
I mean
wait wait no physics we've been in the
space I mean that's gonna count for
something
man listen my boys got three
he's not getting to sleep at night on
this one that's right
Cicero was upset he thinks well what do
you think I mean are we Advanced enough
to be at least interesting
I allow the possibility that the answer
to that is no
I've given this given this example
before but I'm going to put it right out
here and fresh so what animal
is closest to us genetically in the Tree
of Life chimpanzees chimpanzee of course
98 plus almost 99 identical DNS yeah all
right
what's the smartest thing a chimp would
do well he could stack boxes and reach a
banana okay if it sees a banana hanging
from the rafters
it might do some rudimentary sign
language and it will know what size
stick to use
to extract termites from a termite Mound
because apparently they're tasty to
chimps all right so these are smart
things that a chimp does
so what do we do well we have math and
poetry and music and art and the James
Webb Space Telescope and we walked on
the moon
so our urge is to say what a difference
that one and a half percent makes
well that's your ego talking because
maybe the difference between stacking
boxes to reach a banana and the James
Webb Space Telescope is as small as that
one and a half percent difference in DNA
just just consider that okay and here's
how to do that you ready uh
imagine a species
one and a half percent Beyond us
genetically
on the intelligence scale
what would we look like to them
we'd look like chimps right we're one
and a half percent beyond the Chip And
we have a James Webb Space Telescope go
one and a half percent Beyond us uh they
got a Dyson Sphere they they've they
they
is anything we've done gonna impress
them no really and that's just one make
it five percent make it ten percent
at ten percent there is no I cannot
imagine anything we would have done that
would impress them no actually I would
say but I would say at one and a half
percent we would still be somewhat
interesting because we study chimps now
possibly we study chimps because they
are also apes and we are apes and maybe
that is what causes our Intrigue and our
curiosity but uh so but anything beyond
the one and a half percent I mean when
you say ten percent
I mean if if one and a half percent is
the difference between us and chims then
ten percent is unimaginable this is my
point
so yeah and I love the analogy you build
a house and are you do you concern
yourself with displacing the ants no no
all right or do you concern yourself
with any of the wildlife that's on the
plot of land that you just put in the
foundation no right so I I'm not gonna I
cannot say with good conscience that a
sufficiently intelligent alien would
possibly find us interesting and think
of the ego involved in that too yeah all
the people are saying oh the aliens are
coming and they probed my gonads really
they care that much about you really
yeah you're not that sexy and they don't
care that much
so there you go
wow that makes that's very sobering when
you think about it and I'm just trying
to be honest I'm not I don't want it to
be like that but you know it just says
that if we ever are visited by aliens
that most likely they're just going to
take whatever we have yeah and don't
pull out your handgun and shoot at it
right that's not gonna clearly yes
exactly now if there's any thread of
hope that I could offer here um
it's that human knowledge and
achievement is is cumulative
true so you don't have to invent
calculus
because somebody already did already did
you can use it start there and then
invent something new right so maybe it's
not that we have some limit of our
knowledge or our Brilliance and that's
that maybe
every bit of human achievement is a rung
on a ladder that gets added
that'll enable us to see farther and
farther into this universe into the
ideas that con that can comprise the
universe and if that's the case then
we're we're smarter as a species than we
are as individuals
oh there you go that's nice
I like that all right
or the aliens come and they say take us
to your leader and he said it's that AI
algorithm over there right yes go tussle
with our algorithm see it see if you
survive that or just take them to Taylor
Swift and you know the same same
difference
take it to Taylor Swift man
there we go
and believe me the alien would be like
oh my God
oh my God the aliens are swifties
that's why they came here they came they
they couldn't get concert tickets on
their world so anyway uh all right keep
going here we go Stone Courier Stone
Courier says this what a great name by
the way Stone Courier but is it real
yeah exactly I mean it's it's definitely
an a news anchor name Stone carrier
um it says hello Neil hey Chuck I was
looking for some information on space
time what shape is it I know our solar
system and Galaxy are flat discs does
this mean that space time is also a flat
plane also what is the deal with bending
to matter
that's strange way to interact with
mattered don't you think thanks guys
what's the deal
all right
of my book astrophysics for people in a
hurry yep do you know that opening quote
yes the universe is under no obligation
to make sense to you that's my answer to
your guy
oh there you go buddy
no so matter and energy which are the
same thing right
um they're influence on the space-time
Continuum is to curve it
perfect towards it all right okay so the
sun has space-time Continuum curve
towards it so all the planets are
Falling Towards yeah that's fun right
okay but they have speed they have a
sideways speeds which maintains their
orbit but if you take away the sun
they'll fly off at a tangent and never
come back so the the the the the the the
the dimple in the fabric of space-time
right is what contains all of the
orbiting objects around the Sun
so yeah that's how that works like deal
with it and it not only adjusts the
fabric of space-time the time coordinate
is such that your time slows down in the
vicinity of these concentrations of
matter and energy
and so time goes slower for us on
Earth's surface than it does
up in high orbit like a couple hundred
miles up where our GPS satellites orbit
so they have a different time system
than we do right yet as I've said in
another show we get our precise time
from GPS so how's that possible if it's
in another time coordinate system
because we take Einstein's general
theory of relativity published in 1915
calculate how much
faster its time is ticking and correct
it before it tells you what time it is
on your cell phone it still blows my
mind man I mean that is just that alone
should make everybody a fan of science
just that fact and the fact that the man
figured it out in 1915 before there was
any such thing as a calculator or word
space travel or space travel lights
right right right 50 50 years before
anybody any 45 years before anybody went
into space right look at that so yeah
and then people say I don't guess I am
that's just my own it's like okay yeah
what about any science for I have a gut
oh my God
I got this gut man that's what God gave
me this gut for I don't need science
you and your calculations yeah I do what
I feel yeah we'll see how far they get
wow that was great man okay let's go to
Johnny G Johnny G says hello Dr Tyson
and Lord nice hope your day is going
well easy name here for you Chuck okay
thanks Johnny
and I'm writing crayons so you can
understand it exactly I have a question
that keeps me up some nights what caused
the universe to be infinitely hot and
dense was there something before the Big
Bang or did the universe expand and
collapse time and time again before our
universe could come about also what
caused the Big Bang this particular time
well that assumes that there were other
times thank you for your time and for
the many laughs and for making learning
so much fun I love that but love that so
so we devote a fair amount of paid Fair
number of pages in The Cosmic queries
book
uh which I think is you can click a
Click by it on our website
startalkmedia.com I think it's in there
somewhere if not it's on my website if
you can't find it anywhere else
um and on my website you have a choice
of different vendors right if you don't
want if you're anti-amazon you can
there's like Indie Book Sales and this
sort of thing so you have a choice in
there
there's a fair number of pages given to
the origin of the universe and the best
current ideas surrounding it so to be
very small very hot very dense
um that is its birth state
it was burst into that state so it's not
how did it become that right that's how
it was born
and it has to do with this pocket of
energy that slides into a a
configuration
that has such extreme temperatures and
densities where when you are that hot
and that dense you only have one thing
you can do and that's rapidly expand
right so so now this this mechanism that
gives us our understanding of the Big
Bang also makes other Big Bangs so
that's how you get the Multiverse right
okay so you say well what time is it in
this universe we can start the clock at
our big bang but maybe the Multiverse
has its own clock
and we came in existence at 20 minutes
after five on a Tuesday afternoon
that's when we'd start our clock but the
Multiverse might have a meta clock where
it's cranking out the universes one by
one right so um it has to do with with
these
um these energy diagrams
I'm trying to see it explain this in the
best way I can
what I would give an analogy so what
would that be
uh uh if you have a hill
if you have a hill
okay that
collect that
if you have a hill that goes into like a
little Basin and it rains and all the
water collects in that Basin but wait a
minute that's not the lowest place that
water can be right because there's an
even lower point on the other side of
this little bump okay but this other
water collecting there doesn't know that
it keeps building and building and
building
it is possible for the water on this
side of the bump to Tunnel through to
the other side of the bump quantum
physics tells us that right if it does
that then it falls to the bottom
catastrophically and that falling to the
bottom is the birth of Another Universe
there you go
that is it's crazy that's crazy I mean
that's really cool stuff man but right
that that gets that gets super deep I
love it right right
all right let's keep going let's go to
Mark Armstrong and Mark Armstrong says
hello Dr Tyson hello Chuck why does the
Milky Way look like a cloud when you
look up at the sky shouldn't it cover
the entire night sky oh great question I
love that I love that first it looks
like a cloud because you're stuck with
human eyeballs
Galileo with his newly perfected
telescope right said I'm going to look
at the Milky Way
when he did this he saw Stars
so the cloud
while there are gas clouds in the Milky
Way the light that you see is coming
from the puddled merged
um image of light that you cannot
resolve into the component Stars right
okay right and even like like like a
like an LED array if you you know if you
ever see these LED lights it looks like
one big light from a distance from a
distance but when you get up on it you
see oh there's all these tiny little
diodes each one exactly being equally
bright to create
diodes
that's the that's the the third letter
in LED stands for tired light emitting
diode yeah you got it you got it Chuck
so yes that's super cool right so so so
that would be with binoculars or
telescope resolves the the puddled light
into individual Stark first second
the Milky Way is very flat
that the spiral pictures you see of
spiral galaxies if you put them on their
Edge
they're not going to disappear but
they're going to become very not visible
to you okay I'll tell you how flat the
Milky Way it's flatter than a flapjack
than an actual flak check
well if you look at the ratio of the
diameters
it is about it's closer to a crepe
actually oh damn that is okay so now
let's put you inside that crepe okay if
you look horizontally around you all
you're going to see is crepe that's it
but if you look above and below all
right there's not much crepe there to
block your view because it's so thin but
hopefully there's some blueberry compote
so so the solar system is embedded in a
galaxy crepe right and the and the the
the the the galaxy The Milky Way is the
plane of the Galaxy and when we look
above and below we're seeing outside of
the plane of Galaxy season and there's
hardly anything there to block our view
look at that in fact
all data on all galaxies that we have in
our catalogs come from looking above and
below the plane of our galaxy because
you cannot see through it that's how
dense the gas and stars are in our own
Milky Way wow
cool yeah and by the way this is true
with blueberries and pancakes all right
always and so if the blueberry said what
am I doing in here hey all right I see
the rest of the universe God I am so
hungry right now oh
could I go for it Crepes it's been a
while since I've had yeah crepes are fun
crepes are fun pancake variant that you
got to throw in there every now and yeah
man it's always good stuff you know and
and then they they have the best
toppings Crepes you know anyway let's go
to Peter Jacobs he says um okay wait a
minute I love it listen to this Peter
Jacobs listen to this this one's for
Chuck okay
um if the vacuum of space spontaneously
produces pairs of entangled quarks and
Hawking radiation is where one of those
quarks enters a black hole can the
remaining Quark give us information
about what's happening inside the black
hole you know what Peter you're a
jackass okay
just say yes to that question yeah the
answer is yes
[Laughter]
you came with a little bit of extra
Authority at the end right yes yes
all right so first it's a brilliant
question I love it it is and in
entangled particles you allow you to
know what the other particle is doing on
the measurement of a particle so the
suspicion in this question is all the
particles that went outside the black
hole
orphaning their their counterpart inside
the black hole will it tell us what's
inside the black hole the answer is yes
okay except it's
it's
weirder than that
okay ready go ahead the particles that
pop into existence these particle pairs
emerge from the gravitational field
of the black hole right the field
all right so
in this field particle appears
one escapes one falls back in the black
hole now weighs less than it did before
because you just took away some of its
gravity right the gravity gravitational
energy became particles and one particle
escaped
if you inventory
those particles that escape
they match everything the black hole has
ever eaten
so
the idea that a particle that escapes
tells you what's inside the black hole
yeah it is the precise inventory of
everything in its digestive tract
so the black hole does not lose
information this is a famous bet between
Stephen Hawking and yeah and my boy uh
who uh worked with Interstellar um
um Kip Thorne uh who got the Nobel Prize
for his work on discovering
laser uh gravitational waves using ligo
laser interferometer gravitational
Observatory so he's he's all in on this
so he made a bet with Hawking what
happens to the information that falls
into a black hole is it forever lost
then you run the calculation the Hawking
radiation recovers that information
until the black hole disappears entirely
look at that
so information is not lost not lost and
so yes and you're not finding out what's
in there because of what fell in right
just that moment you're finding out what
was in there that it had eaten long ago
look at that yeah this is really great
stuff and so when we say the black hole
evaporates it's not particles escaping
the black hole right it's particles
being created
the energy of the gravitational field
itself and that meant the gravitational
field remembered what happened in the
first place and that's some spooky stuff
that's really crazy man right that's
super cool stuff I mean well Peter thank
you for that question even though you're
a little bit of a jerk for putting it on
me like that
no we don't care okay this is Patrick
wegelinski Patrick waglinski and he says
hey Patrick here from Salt Lake City
Utah hello Dr Tyson and Lord nice if I
were to go on a naked Space Walk
hypothetically what would space feel
like on my skin uh disregarding the fact
that I would be unconscious in about
half a minute of course and to my
understanding getting in a cold pool or
going outside in the winter feels cold
because of the molecules around me are
spreading energy away from my body in
space there's a lot less matter around
you to draw heat away from you and I
think the only way to lose heat would be
from the radiation of my own body right
would that be enough to really feel cold
as a human popsicle cold like in the
movies or could someone theoretically be
comfortable for a short amount of time
without without a suit leaving their
spaceship thanks I like that yeah he
went all in
note to self uh tell them to check out
our temperature explainer where we talk
about
um radiative cooling and heating and
this sort of thing so
uh yes there are no molecules to S to
whisk away your body heat and so you'll
be completely radiative yes you your
body heat will radiate away from your
skin
and it will do it faster than your body
can maintain its temperature
and so you will you will die then your
body temperature will drop rapidly
so uh yeah so yeah you could you could a
few seconds yeah this was correctly
shown in the film 2001 A Space Odyssey
the guy came through the airlock without
his helmet
and uh he's out in space and in the
vacuum of space he hold his breath okay
and which I don't think is the right
thing to do because your lungs will
explode if you do you you the lungs have
normal air pressure air in them right
then you go to zero air pressure right
it'll just blow out your name yeah so
you want to let the air slowly spell the
air come out of come out of you correct
and I think divers know this as well
um and so for depending on certain
diving conditions where the air in your
lungs is compressed once you're already
low so as you come up you can just
exhale for longer than you thought you
could right because the air is
continuing to expand right yeah so it's
an interesting phenomenon when it
happens to you so so yeah I I think you
can survive a bit I'm not going to do
that experiment myself
but yeah and now why would you want to
do this naked though because you know
you've all heard what happens to your
ears
when it gets very cold out your ears
will freeze and they'll crunch off like
a potato chip right
well I'm not worried about my ears oh
that's what I'm saying okay I'm just
saying I'm not worried about my ears
okay
some far more important time I'm just
saying
insane just saying just saying you're
saying yeah so I will be cautious of
that yeah but again it's radiative heat
that's leaving your body until your body
reaches an equilibrium of the radiation
radiative energy that's coming towards
you right and so if you happen to be
near a star you could probably reach an
equilibrium temperature that would be
okay
oh man that's so cool well it's a fun
thought experiment all right let's get
one more question one last question here
we go this is Julia Lind Julia Lind and
or Lindy yeah she says hello Dr Tyson
Lord nice what should be our biggest
priority for exploring the solar system
Landing humans on Mars sending probes to
Europa or Enceladus building a base on
the moon or maybe something else thanks
Julia from Hatboro PA oh okay so I'm
glad I can answer that with high
High Authority and confidence you ready
okay
let's do it all
right all right so here's I I will first
I will not tell people what they should
do right that's not what I do even if it
feels that way sometimes I'm I'm here to
uh try to Enlighten people to inform
them so that when you make a decision in
a free country right where you vote for
people who will go into space you're as
informed as you possibly can be that's
my goal all right so I'm not going to
prioritize destinations in the solar
system what I will say is
it's not all that expensive in the big
picture right everything NASA is doing
is happening with four tenths of one
penny on your tax dollar all right four
tenths that was the dart mission to
deflect an asteroid that's the space
station that's the Artemis Mission back
to the Moon all of that yeah
all right so and that's four tenths of
one percent yeah and I ask you
how much is the universe
worth to you oh look at that yeah so
well that's what I ask and so
uh so yeah let's put people on Mars and
mine an asteroid and and lasso a comet
in case we need some fresh water and
figure out a way to deflect the asteroid
that's headed our way and let's and
space tourism let's do it all
all of it
and then this solar system becomes our
backyard
which is which is cosmically true
was always cosmically true and then
we'll make it a reality for our species
nice oh and by the way and we want to
look for Life on Mars or on Europa yeah
let's do it and by the way their
missions to do this you know but they're
they're bits and pieces and it's not the
backyard plan from NASA that would be
fun nice and by the way there's rare
ingredients on earth like Rare Earth
elements that are common in space yeah
okay energy is common is is plentiful in
space there's a lot of things that are
common in space that are we're fighting
over to gain access to here on Earth
and so space might be the greatest force
of Peace in the world for removing an
entire category of warfare that's
existed with us ever since we stepped
out of the cave
and that's violence committed upon other
tribes
because of limited access to resources
Dan is Chuck oh man that was a good one
man what a this was a great episode
thank you people for all these great
great questions thank you all for that
and like I said if you want to like be
the ones who can ask the questions
that's just five dollars a month that's
it and I'm pretty sure nothing in
Starbucks cost five dollars no
yeah
yeah there might be a hot water and a
tea bag I think is less no you're not
getting that for five dollars no no
maybe if you brought your own cup
and your own tea bags
hot water
all right so this has been Cosmic
queries
grab bag Edition I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
as always bidding you to keep looking up
foreign
[Music]